it's like emotional
yeah start you're getting in and out a
lot
all right i'm gonna continue so what i
was saying is that's just what i was
raised to do
but in my video i said i think it's
important as you said ari to like
have you know diversity or like have it
split oh so
because that set the date that i just
went on
i like what i did is i paid for dinner
and then she paid for dessert like i
think that's fair and we did that for
the rest of the time went on dates like
if we went to an event
i'd pay for the event or vice versa and
then she'd pay for whatever we do next
so we would just go back and forth and i
think that's a good balance to have
um next yeah i don't agree um sorry
i just um i don't know
i just like i'm all about women's
empowerment but i think i'm empowered to
have a standard that the guy on the
first date can pay for dinner
um like my standard for going on a date
with someone is that he can afford
dinner
um and that's totally cool if you want
to set that standard that he does
but for me personally that's just like
i'm not saying he has to pay for every
single thing in the relationship or like
it's like going to be completely
one-sided but
i just find it like i don't know i
that's kind of how i was raised too
um like my brothers even my brothers
like bill always opened the door for me
bill always like hey if we go somewhere
well no they don't do that sorry i'm not
opening the doors they want they don't
sorry that's weird but
yeah i don't know that's that's that's
for me though i don't care if ari does
that
like i just prefer it the other way well
my question is like you know i've
actually been on a date where a guy has
paid for me and he expects me to put out
and i'm like no no that's not gonna
happen and that's also why
i tend to set that precedent for okay
if we're both paying like we both are
like i you cannot expect anything out of
me
and i think that maybe that's maybe me
projecting my fears or
passing passwords as well um but yeah i
think that
also i i think that
maybe it also has to come down to a
socio-economic thing where i
kind of feel maybe i also just feel
uncomfortable when people pay for me
that's just the general thing i don't
know if anybody else experiences that
but
sometimes i just feel really
uncomfortable when people are like oh
let me get this for you i'm like
i i don't deserve this like why why are
you buying this for me why are you
paying for this for me
amanda wanted to say something so
what you just said about deserving i am
like
and this is not a non-answer i promise
i'm like actually fully split
between your two strong opinions
so there's there's a middle ground
i'm gonna talk about energy for a second
um
so there's like masculine and feminine
energy which has nothing to do with like
sex sexual orientation your preference
gender identity like
none of that it's so everyone in here
has a their own unique balance of
masculine and feminine energy
i am more masculine dominant in terms of
my mindset
like i'm very executional i like i'm
running my own company like i'm
i'm more masculine dominant with like
work so masculine is
the i do i get done like that kind of
energy
where the feminine is that i'm soft i
receive i deserve
so it's almost like the sit back and
allowing kind of energy
and so i think there's a time and a
place for both
um similar to you ari i'm like yeah for
sure like i can pay for your dinner and
i can like
bankroll you if you wanted to i'm not
going to but if i wanted to i could
so it's not like it's not like i'm
expecting it because i need to be taken
care of it's
i deserve to be taken care of and so
that's like the worst element i think
that's
that's like that's how i feel too
because i don't i don't need someone to
pay for me
well actually maybe right now maybe even
right now because i don't have a job but
like
yeah girl get that dinner then maybe
maybe right now
um but like normal i don't need someone
too but like
i've just found like i have i think one
two i have five brothers
so like i've talked a lot to like guys
and like my brothers have all told me
like if it like
if he really likes you he would never
let you pay for dinner
and maybe like maybe i'm wrong i don't
know
but i just that's i i just i wouldn't go
on a second date with a guy who didn't
pay for dinner
but there's nothing wrong i think if
someone else wants to you know
that's just like my standard for myself
you know
yeah so i have a question for all the
guys actually
so pearl just brought up the fact that
oh this is how we would know if a guy
really likes us
but do you think that it should be more
so about
his reoccurring actions versus oh
because anybody can just open the door
anybody can just pay for dinner but it
can be both
it can be both one or the other yes
but what i'm trying to say is like do
you guys think that there's more to it
like should we be looking out for more
signs that a guy is interested in us
because
if anything like you know okay yeah
that's great you pay for my dinner
yeah that's standard but is there
something
like maybe it's not so much that but
maybe it's just emotionally being there
for them
um i know dante talks a lot about like
like you talk about oh if i'm dating you
like we're gonna do this and this and
they're and they're really those are
awesome tick tocks
um and and i don't know that maybe sets
the precedent for the type of behavior
that happens in the relationship or
what leads up to like the committing of
a relationship
i don't know i kind of want to hear what
everyone has to say sorry brian i didn't
mean to take your
role of moderator but it was just a
question that was in my head
so
i will say um
in our short survey that we just did all
the guys did say
that they do offer to pay so i don't
know if actually that indicates
a like variation of interest it just
seems like if
for the guys here at least if we're
going to go on a date with you
we will offer to pay i don't know if
that means that like i'm 10 times more
interested in you or not
i don't know if there's like a threshold
i mean do you all think there's a
threshold thing or
for me it's just like if i'm gonna take
on a date i will
offer to pay probably because of like a
societal cultural norm
that we have i'd agree with that too
yeah for sure
way more than another date yeah
i think the same thing i think it's just
kind of standard knowing that i'm going
to pay for the first date
i did want to talk about that a little
bit i've had a couple where i've gone
out with someone for
like maybe three or four dates and
that's
at some point like sometimes they'll
offer to pay like oh
i can get it or we'll get you know
dinner and then we'll get drinks at
another place and they'll pay for drinks
for dessert or whatever
but i've had somewhere i went out with
them three or four times
and they never offered which was okay
but they never were
super grateful they were never like
thank you i really appreciate it
like to me that that's almost a sign of
like okay is this a gracious
person if they're not willing to not
necessarily offer but just like
thank me for paying for the dinner again
so
um to me that was a bit of a turn off
because they were almost
expecting me to to foot the bill every
time
so that's kind of my explanation but
but yes i assume i'm going to pay every
time for at least the first
couple dates i guess i agree with you i
i think the connection is better is it
because i moved
can you assume it right
okay all right
so i like what brian said uh what
john said sorry i think we got to look
at it that
money is just a form of energy and it's
also a form of appreciation of one or
the other pace
so yeah with like in the society
men usually pay on the first day
whatever right
but if the woman is there for a free
meal ticket and not for you
you got to ask yourself is the woman
excited about you
or is she excited about being taken care
of because then that is called the gold
digger
that's called someone who that's not
being taken care of
because it's an appreciation that goes
both ways
now to make it easier i actually never
have the situation
where i never like i literally like
yeah okay maybe i'll pay the first date
right and then
i hang out with girls who are really
cool and
they will say okay i'll pay now and then
you pay and
if the girl really has no money right
she's like
and she like communicate like i'm like
yeah i'm gonna pay for the next
five six seven whatever until you're
good again
because i value you but that's not a per
because i want to have beautiful
experiences with you
like i'm just like if i want to go jet
skiing
with the girls that i'm seeing or the
girl that i'm seeing
right but she can chime in she
that's okay because i want to have that
experience with
you and so i can and i'm excited about
that experience
so i'm gonna pay for that experience
so we're having fun together but what is
the girl and that's what
ari said and i like what the question
ari said is
how do we know if someone is there for
us
right how do we know and i always say
don't watch what they say watch what
they do
now a person can also manipulate
what they do like i think pearl said
that with or ari
oh yeah you could pretend you can open
the door even though open the door is
not
a good example because that's also a
society brainwashed thing
and everybody has two hands and of
course
it's a thing of appreciation i open the
door for you because i'm stronger okay
that's fine but it shouldn't be
something that if you make it expected
and if you
love a person more because they do
things that i expected from society you
love the idea of a person and you don't
have a real connection to that person
you can only have a real connection with
a person if you're excited
for that person for their character like
i love for example
a girl i'm dating right now she's super
loyal right
she's like and you can tell by all her
actions like
she is um
she's on it's like she respects my time
she doesn't get mad
like i do so many tick tock videos i do
so many like
youtube whatever right if i'm like yo
i gotta do this now and like it's early
in the morning
and like like she she might have to go
or
i have to go she's not
she's like yeah she's supportive she's
like yeah do it i'm i'm proud of you i'm
excited for you
it's all good and that's the kind of
things i look for it's someone who
laughs with me it's someone who
uh makes me laugh who i make laugh who's
loyal
who's not there for a free meal ticket
that's literally stupid that's low
conscious
like relationships if you are there if
you're only the relationship
if you expect the guy to do
certain things like my mom and dad told
me
a gentleman is always opening the door
is always paying for this it's always
wearing a suit there's some girls who
like oh he has to wear
certain stuff right how do you then
you're in love with the idea but you're
not in love with a person and i'm all
about being in love with a person
but i think there's like a middle ground
though
like i don't think it's like you know
give me an example like give me an
example
like a specific example because it's all
like theoretical
but if you give me an example we can
like talk about it tell me one example
where you say okay this is the middle
ground like just for me
on a first date like i just wouldn't be
cool with the guy not paying
like on a first date i'm not saying for
the entirety of the relationship
he has to like pay for everything but
like just for me personally
that's just the standard i have for
myself because i think oh no of course
and that's not what i was saying and i'm
not saying that every single person like
if arya wants to do that that's totally
cool
but like i think it's okay to set
standards for women that like we deserve
to be treated a certain way or you know
maybe not even all women like
because you know not all women are nice
you know i don't know so maybe they
not not saying you're not sorry don't
take that the wrong way but like
like just for me like personally like i
just think
like if i communicate to someone that
that's the way i want to be treated like
but let's say ari and i let's say ari
and i we're not going out but let's see
ari and i go on a date right
yeah and aria is like yo i'ma pay right
she's like yo
i'mma pay it's all good she puts her
credit card down
done do you think that she
first of all she doesn't feel less
valued because she's paying
that's just a form of preach like i'm
just pulling down but do you think i
think
uh oh less of her no i'm going to be
like
next time i'm going to be go on a date
with her i'm going to be like yo
i'mma pay like yeah that's it
it doesn't matter who pays first it's
over time it's the
energy balance like amanda talked about
masculine and feminine energy
there's also an energy balance between
two people and if someone just
is there for so to say being taken care
of
then there's no energy balance right i
think
i think you're saying it should be 50 50
right like i think you're saying like
like you should have like equal energy
however you want to like measure that
right yeah
yeah yeah and i agree with you i just
like for me like the standard to go out
with me
personally is like the first couple
dates you have to pay i'm not saying he
has to pay for every single thing but
especially if you ask
me out like you asked me to come you
know let me ask you okay let me ask you
this okay no no
that that's what you need i don't i
usually pay on the first but it's not
even about that i i usually pay on
let me ask you this like let's say you
go out you said the first couple days
usually they must pay right
let's say you go out with like the
coolest guy you have so much fun he
makes you laugh
right he pays the first date you go on
the second date you go to the movies you
have so much fun you have a great
conversation
and then you go to dinner and he's like
uh
you pay like 50 50. and then you like
this is like the dopest guy you met like
for a longest time
i don't think you're gonna like my
answer and you got
you are
[Music]
he asked me to dinner if he asked me to
dinner you asked me to go
you should be obligated to pay correct
yeah so let's say you ask a guy
are you not obligated to pay no why not
why not i don't know what is the balance
in that that's what i'm saying because
it sounds like an entitlement thing to
me not just you personally but i've
heard other girls say that
but why like what do you mean
like why if he has to pick you if he
asks you out why don't you have to pay
for him if he if you ask him out
where's the difference i i just feel
like that's the standard i have for me
and if you don't like if you don't have
that that's what i'm asking though is
like
why yeah it's not a standard it's a
story you have in your mind
about how you feel uh a
guy you like should act it's not a
standard it's literally a trained
thing but it's okay because that's your
preference
i'm not taking away your prep if that's
what you want to do i'm just saying
that i don't see a balance in that
but if that's your preference you will
find someone who will do that
right but this is not even important
like literally is that
you guys said priorities is that really
important
so the hypothetical question you said it
was like third or fourth date
i don't know first date i wouldn't be
cool with it later down the road maybe
i okay so sorry i don't mean too
it's about how that person is right it's
about
how that person is all together as
a person it's not mathematically it's
not a mathematical structure
like you count in your head oh i'm gonna
pay the
he's gonna pay the first three days the
first four days and then i'm gonna pay
for one and then he's gonna pay three
dates again and i'm gonna
if you have this head connection it's
always gonna be a relationship that's
gonna be in your head
but if it's really a person like i had
girls like literally where i was like
making
more money too and they were like
struggling right now right
but i didn't feel like i was giving
something
away from me when i like just was like i
invited her for like
like a month or even like seven weeks
straight
and even on because she was so cool she
was like man i really don't like you
doing this but i was like that's exactly
why i'm doing it because you don't
expect it for me
you don't expect it for me but as soon
as
you raise the law that's not real love
so to be honest like i don't even really
like going to dinner i feel like if i
could go on a date i'd just play
basketball
i don't know about like like yeah i like
that answer
like to be honest like i feel like my
ideal dates don't cost anything i go
like hiking maybe play basketball
i love that that's great dates yeah okay
i'll i'll kill you in one-on-one because
i played in college you know what i mean
real quick
i kind of before casey chimes in um
i want to just kind of talk about my
date yesterday
because i walked into so i ubered over
to this guy's place he doesn't have cope
and by the way he showed me his antibody
test
and i walked it i basically walked to
his apartment and he texted me he's like
hey can't come to the door right now
i'm like why he goes i'm playing cop do
you leave immediately
no i didn't leave immediately but i have
a video you should have
really okay because like i basically
i had walked in there and he was like he
buzzed me and he didn't even get the
door
and then i have a video of him playing
cod
as i'm sitting there watching him i'm
like okay
what do i do but um yeah i don't know
it's kind of like
it was a it's a very i feel like during
the day you don't really know what to
think
and then like especially for how like
men should treat you especially with
heterosexual
relationships but i didn't realize until
like in retrospect
that oh my god i mean maybe like this is
where pearl's coming in where it's like
okay maybe the guy should have gotten
the door maybe the guy should have like
because in that moment i really did feel
like really disrespected i don't know
but also did you meet him on tinder
or what no we had met we had met so he
we have mutual friends or whatever and
we also met on a dating app through that
because essence is a very small city but
um yeah i don't use tinder in your past
relationships already did the guys
did the guys get the door for you did
they come to the door like were they
more respectful than that or no
yeah they were yeah i'd say so so would
you say that's like what you expect from
yourself
as a guy to do that or no i feel like
i don't really know because i haven't
been in a relationship in a while that's
the problem
yeah if you know what you deserve and
you know what you're worth then you're
gonna know that [ __ ] right when it
happens that's my point
that is true yeah maybe i should have
walked away i don't know and then
and then and during the day i was like
oh this is actually like not that bad
but oh my god it just the red flag just
kept coming out and i was like
i don't know casey needs to like speak
so i want to let him and then we'll get
back to my day um afterward
because i gotta tell i gotta spill the
tea for you guys cause it's really funny
sounds good i have to just go teach here
in just a moment so just so i can
contribute something to this
i think what we can see is
communication plays a really big role
and
even when it comes to things like asking
either someone out to dinner or paying
for that dinner
because at least as a guy i hope that me
offering to pay for dinner
or me just trying to pay the bill i hope
that does not just automatically convey
interest for example i took a staff
member of mine that's on my journal out
to dinner the other day as a thank you
and i did that simply as a professional
courtesy